we're going straight to Hamburg now
where King Charles has just arrived at
Hamburg station there this is his first
date visit with the queen consort and
he's just arrived at Hamburg station as
I said by train where he is we are
expecting him to lay flowers at the
Kindle transport Memorial this is the
final day of the king's visit to Germany
and he is going to Hamburg as I said
they've got a full day they're going to
lay flowers
right up against that light
yeah the king arriving in Hamburg so as
I was saying they are going to there he
is King Charles
[Applause]
so a big cheer for King Charles and the
queen console I think I supported her
two there let's bring in Laura bundock's
our Royal correspondent uh Laura a big
chair for him but it is a pertinent trip
well a pattern pertinent final day isn't
it this trip specifically to the city of
Humber
foreign
that's right this is day three of this
state visit the first date visit of the
new Reign the king arriving at Hamburg
station he caught the train from Berlin
this morning accompanied by the German
president and the president's wife the
king and the queen concert are here in
Hamburg for a somber start to the day
they will be visiting the Kinder
transport Memorial at tamberg station
the king very much part of this Memorial
which marks the efforts to save the
lives of ten thousand children from
Nazism he referenced it in his speech to
the bundestag yesterday he will go to
the memorial here in Hamburg and then
make his way to another Memorial where
we are the Church of Nikolai this church
is in a memorial itself the the body of
the church is a complete ruin now but
it's stands as a reminder and a symbol
of warning against war and if the King
was talking about the importance of
reconciliation after World War II
yesterday then perhaps Hamburg
is the most symbolic place he could come
to this summer will be the 80th
anniversary of hamburg's bombings you
can see the king now coming out of the
train station
umbrellas in hand because it is
absolutely pouring with rain here in
Hamburg he will need that umbrella he's
actually heading out onto the water at
the port a little later on it will be a
rather wet time there but it was back in
July 1943 when the Allies over the space
of just eight days dropped 9 000 tons of
bombs on the city here it created a
firestorm and killed 37
000 civilians it was the heaviest
assault in the history of aerial Warfare
and they will after leaving the station
be coming to mark that moment in what
we're told will be a somber moment of
reflection there will be wreath laying
here at some Nikolai Church the memorial
which as I said said
says it is now a symbol of warning
against the horrors of War
okay Laura thank you so much what have
they been doing so far they were
originally meant to go to Paris
obviously that leg of the tour was
canceled what have they done in the
first two days of their trip
that's right let's pause perhaps just
follow this picture this is the memorial
there you can see it quite clearly
outside the station as I say this is a
memorial
um
to the Kinder transport that's something
the King has been closely involved with
over the years and it marks the efforts
to save the lives of ten thousand
children from the Nazis when they were
brought to the UK during the war can't
really make him out of amid that sea of
umbrellas there but this trip this first
state visit of a new Reign has been a
very significant moment for the king
you're right it was supposed to start in
France but those political protests
meant that leg has been postponed and so
it was Germany given the honor of
hosting the king and Germany has pulled
out all the stops right from the moment
the king entered German airspace where
military jets escorted his plane into
Berlin there was the Grand ceremonial
welcome at Brandenburg gate
he was the first visiting head of state
to be given the big welcome at at the
gate before that white Thai State
banquet on Wednesday evening and
yesterday for the first time as Monarch
the king addressed the bundestag the
first British monarch to do so in a
speech that was very well received here
he spoke with great warmth and affection
it was all about trying to restore
relations after brexit and he spoke
about the historic alliances between
Britain and Germany the importance the
significance of
anglo-german relations I mean much of
that speech given in German and the
significance of that certainly not lost
on the politicians there the speech
itself lasted 24 23 minutes but there
was a two-minute Standing Ovation after
it for the king and of the other
engagements we've seen him and the king
queen consort
involved in over the last two days very
much in reflecting the common interest
that the that the shared values of both
Germany and England and the interests of
the couple themselves of the King has
attended a number of environmental
engagements the queen concept yesterday
was at the Opera in Berlin this
afternoon in Hamburg she will meet the
illustrator of The Garofalo at a local
school where there will be an art and a
reading session the king will be finding
out more about the green efforts here in
Harbor as he heads to the port to learn
about green energy hydrogen storage as
well something we know is close to his
heart but before all that as I say it is
a much more somber start to the day here
as he visits these memorials the Kinder
transport Memorial we see him at now and
then he'll be making his way to this
church the Nikolai church right in the
center of Hamburg nothing is left of the
church pretty much apart from this huge
spire and the reason the Spy which was
at one point the tallest in the world
survives is because it was used as a
landmark
for the Allied Fleet they used it as a
landmark to know where to drop their
bombs which resulted as I was saying in
the deaths of 37 000 civilians it was a
huge turning point in the Allied
methods
in the second world war but we have the
first part of this engagement here at
Hamburg station at the kinder transport
Memorial there
okay Laura thank you so much Laura there
in a rainy Hamburg such a shame isn't it
difficult to see with all those Rollies
up but the latest there from the king
and queen consorts trip to Germany